حاله جدليه وغضب اهالي احد مراكز محافظه
كفر الشيخ المصريه اثاره عرض الحلقات
الاولى من المسلسل الكوميدي بالطو
باعتباره يسيء لهم ويسخر منهم المسلسل
تدور احداثه في اطار كوميدي وساخر بشان
تكليف طبيب شاب في وحده صحيه باحدى قرى
مركز مطوبس ومن ثم يجد نفسه فجاه مديرا
لتلك الوحده الصحيه ومسؤولا عن كل شيء
فيها من دون سابق خبره ورغم وجود تنويه
قبل عرض كل حلقه بان الاحداث من وحي خيال
الكاتب لا تمت للواقع بالصله لان غضب
اهالي مركز طوبس بمحافظه كفر الشيخ دفع
البرلماني محمد سعد لتقديم بيان عاجل
بالتوقف الفوري لوقف عرض المسلسل طالت
الانتقادات مسلسل بالطو واثير الجدل حوله
والسبب رؤيه البعض اهانه لمركز مطوبس
بمدينه كفر الشيخ المصريه فما القصه
المسلسل الكوميدي
مسلسل احمد عاطف نفى اي ارتباط بين احداث
المسلسل واهالي القريه فمقدمه المسلسل
تحمل تنويه الاحداث لا تمت للوقع بالصله
وانما محض خيال ولكن هذا التوضيح لم يقف
حائلا بين المسلسل وبين المحامي صبري
الرخام الذي صمم على تقديم بلاغ للنائب
العام يطالب فيه بوقف عرض المسلسل دفاعا
عن اهل قريته لصباح العربيه ندى حجازي كفر
الشيخ على كل نحاول نفهم هذا الجدل من
القاهره ينضمون الكاتب والصحفي رمضان
العباسي وهو واحد من ابناء مدينه مطوبس
التي تناولها مسلسل بالطو وايضا ينضم
الينا عبر سكايب الناقد الفني محمد عبد
الرحمن اهلا بكما ابدا معك رمضان لماذا
اثار مسلسل بالطو كل هذا الغضب بين اهالي
القريه
صباح الخير عليكم وعلى الساده المستمعين
الحقيقه احنا مش ضد الفن ولا ضد الابداع
على الاطلاق لكن ضد الاستخفاف بمنطقه مهمه
في جغرافيا مصر وفي تاريخ مصر وفي حضاره
مصر
ضد الاستهانه بالناس
ضد السخريه اللي ظهرت وكان لها رد فعل من
الحلقات الاولى
السخريه ظهرت في عده اشياء اولا في
استخدام الاسم
اسم القريه اللي استخدمها
دكتور احمد عاطف
المؤلف وهو راجل طبيب وان كان يكون بيتكلم
عن المعاناه بتاعته او معاناه التكليف او
البيروقراطيه او الروتين اللي موجود في
عمليه التكليف لكن اولا ما كانش ينفع باي
حال من الاحوال انه يستهين باهالي مطوبس
ولا باهالي القريه فبدا الاستهانه من خلال
الاختيار الاسم
طرشوخ الليف لم يكن موفق على الاطلاق في
اختيار هذا الاسم لان هذا الاسم اولا فيه
اساعه رقم 2 ظهرت
يا استاذ رمضان لما بنحكي عن عمل كوميدي
عمل فيه سخريه فيه ضحك الناس بتضل تضحك
على كل مشهد من اوله لاخره بالتالي يعني
لماذا التدقيق على امور اصلا لا تمت
للواقع بصله اصلا يعني اليوم الزمن
وهالدنيا تحتاج انه الناس تضحك باعمال
بامان ظلاميه المشاهد التي تحدث من اخبار
واحداث حولنا
ونحن بالفعل انا معك تماما محتاجين احنا
محتاجين فعلا الكوميديا لان الكوميديا
النهارده مهمه في وقت غابت في الكوميديا
عن الاعمال الفنيه بشكل كبير لكن
الكوميديا ما تكونش على حساب
على حساب الناس على حساب
كرامتهم على حساب الاستخفاف بيهم على حساب
اظهارهم بهذه الصوره البدائيه
في مشاهد عايز بس الاستاذ عمر المهندس في
تصويره للمشاهد لم يكن موفق على الاطلاق
في مشاهد كثير في لما
بطل المسلسل لما كان بيستخدم وسائل
المواصلات البدائيه عفوا اللي هي الحمار
والحوار الذي دار بيني وبين الحمار فيها
في وسيله في في مظهر يظهر اهالي مطوبس
بشيء من السخريه في مشهد اخر يتحدث عن
اهالي مطوبس وكانهم يعني يعيشون على شيء
من البدائيه والدجل والشعوذه في مشهد
مرزوق اطفاء النار في مشاهد متعدده للاسف
تكرس او تظهر
مطوبس واهلها بغير الحقيقه مطوبس لازم
نعلم جميعا انها اذا كان جمال حمدان اتكلم
عن مصر بانها جغرافيه عبقريه المكان في
انها عبقريه المكان الجغرافي فان مطوبس
عبقريه او جغرافيه المكان في مصر بحيث
مطوبس بتطل على ثلاثه انواع من المياه
مياه بحيره وبحر ونيل مطوبس انجبت العديد
من الزعماء الذين اثروا في تاريخ مصر
وحضرتها ثقافيا وتاريخيا وادبيا وممكن حتى
علميا مطوبس كان من الاولى وكنت ادعو
الدكتور احمد
عاطف ان يقرا تاريخ مطوبس ان يقرا الكتاب
مطوبس هو اكثرهم يعني كان يقرا الذهبي كان
يقرا
لكاتبنا الكبير سمير المنزلاوي كان يقرا
لجارنا خير شلبي قد
السيد محمد كما سمعتها لقريه مطوبس يرون
ان المسلسل يهين للاهالي ويتضمن عبارات
يتضمن الفاظ مسيئه للقريه يعني ما رايكم
بالمسلسل اولا وكيف تردون على شكاوي اهالي
القريه
اللي موجوده حاليا على الساحه ونجاح فاجئو
لانهم هم مش منهم الصف الاول وما كانش في
تبريد كبير للمسلسل لكن لو هنرد بس على
طبعا كل الاحترام لاهالي اي مركز في ريف
مصر لكن خليني ارد في نقط سريعه اولا
الاحداث تدور في قريه اسمها طرشوخ الريف
غير موجوده على الخريطه يعني هي قريه يعني
زي زي المزاريطه في مسلسل بالتالي حتى من
الناحيه القانونيه ما فيش اي اساءه او اي
حاجه ممكن تتاخذ هو النقطه انه بيتقال في
اليافطه بتاعه المسلسل انه الطرشيخ الليف
دي تبع مركز مطوبس دي حتى ممكن يعاد
منتجها اذا فرضت ان الموضوع سيصل هذه
الازمه ده غير ان فكره المنع يا استاذ
العزيزه احنا وصلنا للحلقه السادسه فتسلسل
موجود على كل المنصات يعني هو طبعا منصه
ولكن بيتم كاردته فهو متاح منعه بقى شيء
مستحيل النقطه الثانيه انا انا فعلا
انبسطت دلوقتي بيتكلموا استاذ رمضان ومن
التقرير اني عرفت معلومات عنه بس انا
مكنتش عارفها بالتالي انصح اهالي مطوبس
بدل من توجيه الغضب للمسلسل الذي لم يصور
هناك ان هم يعملوا حمله للتعريف
المحترمه والشخصيات التاريخيه اللي خرجت
منها كمان انا معلش هتحفظ على الملاحظه
اللي انا اضيفك العزيز على بشر الحمار
اللي كان في الحلقه السادسه انه ده مشهد
فانتازي كوميدي هو يعني اكيد الحمار في
مطوبس ما بيتكلمش وبعدين احنا
الحمار في طرشوخ الليف مش في مطوبس يعني
هي يعني المكان الاكبر لكن هو مش موجود في
الاحداث خالص الموضوع فانتازي بياخد بعض
البوطائع الحقيقيه اللي حصلت للمؤلف
ومركبها على علم خيالي يعني حتى احمد عاطف
قال لي ملاحظه هي ال الديكور المصحه اللي
موجود في المسلسل
ده ديكور خيالي يعني ما فيش بصحه في اي
منطقه ريفيه بهذا الشكل يعني ومعلش يعني
كمان بالادب العربي جحا وحماره وكل القصص
الخياليه عن جحا والحمار يعني فلا مانع من
ان يكون هناك حوارات مع الحمار في اعمال
دراميه مثل هكذا عمل طب اليوم بس سؤال
استاذ عبد الرحمن لو انت من محافظه مثلا
انعمل عليها برضه عمل كنت رح تزعل تشعر
بالغضب والغيره على المنطقه اللي انت جيت
منها يعني لا ادري من اي محافظه او اي
منطقه انت من مصر هل كان ستراودك نفس
المشاعر وانا انا من مدينه الجيزه وما
بتجيش في الضلمه كتير ليه لكن هو طبعا انا
فاهم منطق اهلي مطوبس انه الناس هتهزر مع
بعض ويقول له هو الحمار عندكم بيتكلم انا
عارف ان دي طبيعه للاسف المصريين بيحبوا
يهزروا على المحافظات بينهم لكن الدراما
هنا بريئه يعني الدراما مش متعمده للاساءه
ومش هينفع نعمل كل المسلسلات كانها الزمن
يعني ده في ناس بقت فاكره ان المزاريطه
مكان حقيقي من طول نجاح المسلسل بس مثلا
في المزاريط عملوا اللهجه صح يعني عاملين
لهجه كانها لهجه احدى الكره او المدن في
الصيد انا شايف ان المفروض ما زعلش الا
اذا كان في تشويه متعمد وتشويه معلوماتي
متعمد يعني مثلا يكون بيتقال ان زي مثلا
حصل الموقف الشهير بتاع فيلم العار ان هم
صوروا
رمضان ومحمد شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا لكم